RYAN MATSUMOTO: Hi.
My name is Ryan.
And I'd like to show you around
the Google Cloud Console, where
you can manage your Google
Cloud resources directly
from the web.
In the next few minutes, we'll
explore several key areas
of the console that can
help you as you begin
your journey with Google Cloud.
Ready?
Let's get started.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Google Cloud resources are the
fundamental components that
make up Google Cloud Services.
These may include Compute Engine
virtual machines, Cloud Storage
buckets, Cloud SQL database
instances, and more.
Resources are organized
hierarchically
using projects and folders.
Projects are how you group
resources together and are
the first level
of the hierarchy.
All resources must belong
to exactly one project.
So a given Compute
Engine virtual machine
or a Cloud Storage bucket
would belong to one project.
Optionally, projects can
belong to organizations,
which provide
centralized visibility
and control across all
projects in a given org.
An organization helps
administrators for your company
or group manage billing or
security across many projects.
You can further organize your
company's departments or teams
into folders.
Folders can contain
projects, and also
subfolders for further
structure and nesting.
When you open
console.cloud.google.com,
here's the landing
page dashboard.
At the top, you can see
which Google Cloud project
you're currently viewing.
You can click the
project name to switch
to a different project.
If you do so, you'll
see the resources
for your other project.
You can also create a
new project right here.
Another key area of the console
is the left navigation menu,
located in the top-left corner.
This menu helps you access
your Google Cloud Services.
For example, if you navigate
to the Cloud Storage section,
you can create new Cloud
Storage buckets, upload objects,
and download objects.
You can also pin your
favorite products
to the top for easy access.
I'll pin Storage to make sure
I can quickly get to my buckets
next time.
Next up, we have the
search bar, which
allows you to quickly search
for Google Cloud products,
resources, and documentation.
For example, you could
search for the name
of one of your other projects
if you want to switch to it.
If you search for
Cloud Run, you'll
see links to the Cloud Run
section of the Console,
documentation and tutorials
related to Cloud Run,
and a list of Cloud
Run-related APIs that you
might want to manage.
The home dashboard provides
a high-level overview
of your Google Cloud
project, giving you
information about
key metrics, billing,
and getting started guides.
The dashboard is
customizable, allowing
you to show, hide, and
reorder the different cards
how you want.
There's also the
Activity stream,
which shows you information
about all the activities
happening across your Google
Cloud resources in one place.
For example, you can
see which projects
have been updated, what
your teammates are doing,
or audit access to your
Google Cloud resources.
Next is the APIs and
Services section,
where you can do things
like enable or disable APIs,
view API usage information,
and manage credentials.
If you click Enable APIs
and Services at the top,
you'll be brought
to the API Library.
This is where you
can view information
about the hundreds of different
Google Cloud APIs across areas
like Maps, Machine Learning,
Google Workspace, and more.
If you click on
Cloud Vision API,
you'll be brought to the Cloud
Vision API page, where you can
click Enable to enable the API.
This allows you
to use the Vision
API in your applications.
If you ever get stuck,
the Support section
is also accessible right
from the navigation menu.
You can get help via
chat, over the phone,
or from other community members.
There are several
different support offerings
that you can compare
and contrast to see what
makes the most sense for you.
Another key part of the console
is Cloud Identity and Access
Management, or Cloud IAM.
Here, you can manage and create
permissions for your Google
Cloud resources.
As your team grows,
you can grant access
to teammates in Cloud IAM.
You can add users, groups,
or service accounts
and assign them
any number of roles
to grant them the
permission they need.
For example, you can
add your friend James
as an editor for your
Google Cloud project.
Next up, we have Cloud
Shell, which provides you
with command-line access
to your cloud resources
directly from your web browser.
Powered by a small virtual
machine with persistent disk
space, it comes pre-installed
with helpful tools
like the Google Cloud
SDK, Docker, git,
and various
programming languages.
This makes it easy to get
started and explore Google
Cloud without having to
download additional software
to your local device.
There's also Cloud
Shell Editor, which
makes it easy for you
to write code directly
from your web browser and
deploy it to the cloud.
The Billing section
of the console
is where you can
manage billing accounts
and link your projects to them.
A Cloud Billing
account defines who
pays for a given set of
Google Cloud resources.
To use Google
Cloud Services, you
must have a valid
billing account linked
to your Google Cloud projects.
The billing account can be
linked to payment methods,
like a free trial, a credit
card, or a bank account.
There are also interactive
quick-start experiences
available in the Console.
These tutorials,
which you can find
on the home dashboard in
the Getting Started section,
guide you through how to
accomplish essential tasks
with different cloud products.
For example, this
tutorial guides you
through how to create
a Cloud Storage bucket,
upload a file to the bucket,
and delete the bucket.
And you can do this all
in under five minutes.
Beyond the web portal,
the Google Cloud Console
is also available on
Android and iOS mobile apps.
You can use these to monitor
and manage your Google Cloud
applications on the go.
So there you have
it, an overview
of what the Google Cloud Console
is and how you can get started.
Make sure to check out the
other episodes of Google Cloud
Essentials, where we
cover the Google Cloud
SDK, the free trial,
key use cases, and more.
I can't wait to see what
you built with Google Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]